Hello everybody!
Hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi.
Hello, Sensei, hello, Sensei.
Sensei, Sensei.
Welcome back.
Welcome back, welcome back, welcome back.
I'm realizing the like spoilers in this opening.
I don't think I've ever really paid so much attention.
attention to it.
Hello, hello, hello.
Welcome, welcome, welcome.
Welcome, welcome.
A director
sensei.
Me too cute today and every day.
Stop it.
I feel, I'm so nervous.
I want to thank Nexon for sponsoring me for this stream.
Oh, I get so nervous though.
Like, I mean, obviously with sponsored streams, but also, I
don't know.
I just, you know, I don't show off my Blue Archive account,
and I feel it's like my personal thing, you know?
So I feel like all like, oh, you guys are getting to see my
account.
It makes me nervous.
I'm Merlock.
Happy birthday!
Maybe some of you guys have seen me on the Blue Archive
channel.
I played a little bit with RC.
More chairs for Kowaru.
Yeah.
We love our creep.
How am I a creep?
It's so crazy.
I like decorated my cafe.
And then I was like, wait a second.
Everyone's going to be seeing it.
So basically in the game, you have, I'll show you my cafe.
But then like a couple updates ago, they updated it.
where other people can like visit your own cafe right but i
had mine decorated in a way that and then i was like wait
other people are gonna be able to come to my cafe
happy to meet you let's begin a motion expo thank you yes i
hope next year too thank you How many polls to get Minto's
student character?
Oh, jeez.
I'm not the student, though.
I'm sensei, I'm sensei, I'm sensei, I'm sensei.
I'm sensei, I'm sensei, I'm sensei.
This, this, I'm big fan of this opening, though.
The song is so good.
But you know, there's something, there's a, sometimes I'll
go to like, Yostar store in Akihabara or something, and
they'll be playing...
you know one of the original blue archive opening songs and
i'm like oh man it's so nostalgic hearing
it so a little bit of a schedule today mito sensei ojo p is
fire
so it i don't know there's something i love something about
the song just like exudes I mean this one too though I
really feel it just exudes like blue archive energy when I
think of blue archive I mean obviously I think of blue but
like everything is so I don't know everything is so... it
just has like an energy I will say if you don't know much
about Blue archive i'll try and do my best to explain some
things with the spoiler free very general vague stuff um
just don't pay attention much to this opening right um but i
will say that like the this game is so i don't know we'll
give more into it i like i said i do have a schedule yeah
don't don't look
but how exciting we'll we'll head on in i have no context
for the spoilers anyway we will be doing a little bit of the
main story today which is so exciting um i will uh i'll also
say my schedule has been like so crazy so um you know i've
sometimes logging in part for my even just but Mika yeah
she's one of my she's one of my home screen students
swimsuit Mika so cute speak speak to me Mika say something
never mind she's shy oh hi
Does anyone have a favorite memorial lobby?
Here, I can show you what I have.
I have a swimsuit, Mika.
Obviously.
I love swimsuit, Hina's.
So, so cute.
Swinsuit's safe.
Oh,
yes, yes, yes.
Of course.
Swimsoos!
The song is so great.
Sometimes I will just like put on the music.
I mean, that's another great thing about Blue Art Cover It
is the music.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Can you guys guess my favorites?
Of course, the PGM for this one is so cute too.
I've read so many...
I don't know if I can talk about that.
Oh, wait.
I only have these ones.
I actually forgot that I had Kanoui in my lineup, but...
Yes.
She's very pretty.
very pretty uh let's see well a couple things we'll be doing
today of course we will be going through the gotcha right we
have a dress mootski very very cute would look great with
all of my other dress characters you're saving for dress
hina i very much love dress hina and then we will also be We
need our problem-solver.
Girlies.
Horrible rumor that I'm stinky.
Who could be spreading such lies?
I think actually the Haruka one is so cute.
But admittedly, I don't use Haruka very often.
So, I think.
But I really love the bow on the back of her head.
They both look so cute.
And this one, the Memorial Lobby looks so great.
to grab them we we will get as you can see i have not uh
have not uh tried at all oh
let's see look how cute she is uh deals 3 36 percent attack
as damage to one enemy not excessive at all no no no You got
Mutsuki in 60 polls!
What the heck?
Mine will...
I'll do it.
You even better.
I'll get her...
In one poll.
It will be the first one.
Ten poll, but...
It will be the very...
First one that...
Well...
The very...
The very first student...
In that ten poll will be...
Will be her.
First try.
For sure.
We'll also be looking a bit at the uh about the uh the main
story today um it might be slight spoilers but actually I'm
really enjoying this stuff with the fox squad um it's it's
all kind of the lore stuff is very interesting I'm a big fan
of that kind of like you know urban legend stuff so I'm very
excited to read more about it.
It's all warm-ups until the first try.
Anyways, so true.
I hope you have better pulls than R.C.
Where's her not good?
Were they not good?
The...
We'll talk more about the story once we get into it.
And I'll give...
So, it's kind of tough to give, like, a summary, huh?
But...
talk a little bit about it one thing about blue archive is
there's you know you'll have all your different students you
have all your different schools and your clubs and
everything but it's kind of nice that you can see how they
come together but also you can focus on their individual
stories as well like the the different volumes of the main
story kind of go about the different schools
You can kind of, you can get pretty in-depth, like, stories
on a lot of the different schools and all.
So, notice how Koharu is pinned.
What do you want from me?
Can I help you?
Though, there, I mean, there are a good number of students.
I don't have.
She will be ours today.
And don't tell me to claim Shiroko.
my elf elif so that i can i can i can five star her
immediately
don't tell me to exchange i don't want to hear it but yeah
honestly i feel like on stream my gotcha luck has been so
good but i mean i mean this is quite a quite a bit of girls
that there's some, you know, unique characters that I have
not been able to pull as well.
But, um, you know.
It's kind of crazy how I haven't pulled her yet.
Maybe today will be the day.
It's our luck today.
Why would you say that?
No, no.
I've never jinxed anything before.
Fat finger space.
Oh my god, that would be horrific.
Stop.
It's kind of nuts.
You haven't even pulled her normally.
That's what I'm saying!
So it's become like a meme with myself at this point.
So, yeah.
Konnichiwa, Mitsensei.
Konnichiwa!
If you have Miyako swimsuit or Yuzu made, then your cafe
would be perfect.
We can take a check.
Take a look at my cafe.
Let's see who?
Oh.
We have some patrons waiting.
And no show.
Everybody's waiting for the show to begin.
Everybody's...
Oh, hello.
Woo!
Lucky, lucky.
Level 20 Nanomi?
Well, everybody's waiting for the activities to begin.
But I am not inviting anybody because I would like to try to
do...
I would like to try to do the Momo talks for Mutsuki and
Haruka.
So let's see.
Oh, we have another eager...
Eager patron.
You haven't changed the cafe?
What are you talking about?
This is my normal cafe!
Hey!
What do we talk?
What do you mean?
This is the normal cafe!
Anyway.
We'll give them some privacy.
Enhance.
Shall we though?
I mean, I don't want to like...
I don't want to, you know, go so crazy, but should we do
some polls?
I think we should.
I think we'll try for Mutsuki first, and then Haruka after.
But I believe, I trust, that we will...
For first try.
Check it out.
Watch this.
I'm gonna close my eyes.
I told you what would be Mutsuki!
I told you all.
I told you Mutsuki would be the first character in my post!
I told you!
I called it!
I showed you all!
Maybe I just skip.
Oh, what?
I thought.
Wait.
I didn't get to...
try and pull during when she uh when she was the the banner
so new student let's go let's go well i haven't done a
recruit in a while because i i was like oh well i should
save for stream i knew this was coming up so let's see
Alright, let's try again.
Erika cute though, she's very cute.
She's very cute.
Oh my gosh, that Plana is so cute!
Oh god, Plana!
That's new though, no, right?
The Plana and Arona like...
I want them... Don't they have one where they both do it at
the same time?
I haven't... Like I said, I haven't...
in a long time because I was like preparing for stream.
It's new, it's so cute.
Oh please, oh please.
Oh please.
Come on, I know we can do it.
Come on.
If we get her sub 60, I think it'll be great.
You haven't seen Plana yourself?
Well, you do have to go through the main story.
to...
to have her with you.
So...
Oh, whoops, I forgot that.
There we go.
So read, everybody, read!
They gotta read.
I am...
Please!
Crying!
Please, my streamer look!
Please, please!
Wait, when I see her though, it's still so exciting, right?
Guys, I need your energy.
Guys!
Guys, I need your energy!
I need your energy for this next one.
Please!
Are you sending it, yeah?
Yes!
Take my gotcha luck!
Okay!
It's gonna happen.
So cute.
Mincey, you're getting her!
You have enough!
Okay.
They do...
You know, obviously this is a sponsored stream.
They do give me...
Pyroxians to use.
If I have any left over, I get to keep them!
You don't understand!
Do you know how many unique characters I don't have?
I need to keep!
We got any good?
Is this all I get?
Please, game.
At least, at least the Butkin Haruka are not unique.
Which means that you can pull them anytime, but...
Oh!
Those...
Such thing is a death pyros.
It's true.
Where's my streamer luck?
Oh my gosh.
But, you know, obviously if you do...
If you do so many recruits, you can grab somebody.
You know, you can recruit them.
It's like, you know, many other gacha games in that regard.
I think I've been told to pull.
Okay, I've been told to pull 100 times.
You got her in 90?
Okay, okay.
Thank you for the pink!
90.
I'm recording again.
I could feel the emotion.
There's Haruka.
That's like not Musi.
It's like the opposite of Musi.
It's like, maybe...
Okay, guys, this is our last chance before...
We will come back to Gacha.
Don't worry.
If I don't get her now, we will come back.
We can't give up.
Maybe I just need a little break, you know?
Or I'll get her now.
I'll get her now.
Oh, but Plana is so cute.
I don't mind.
Yeah.
We gotta clear the bad luck away.
She's just still talking.
That's fine.
Plata, you were our only hope.
Next time.
We'll come back.
Don't worry.
The stream is not over yet.
We're here for a while.
But I do want to show off a little bit of the story.
Is that okay with you guys?
Well, it must be.
because it's what I've been asked to do.
And also, I think the story is so interesting.
So, let's see.
Story.
We are on Main Story Act 2.
Again, probably slight spoilers for if you don't know.
It's really, like I said, it's pretty tough to kind of give
like an...
Give a summary.
Basically, we are in Kivotos.
there's many schools cute girls you have in how do you
describe um bizarre things happen around this place um i'm
i'm so all of this oh wait this i'm no spoilers but this i'm
like oh oh
It is a very good story.
I am a bit behind on Act 1.
Yes, please don't notice.
Do you have time to read always?
But it's not much, but here's a little bit of luck I have.
Thank you.
But I, you know.
We're on Main Story Act 2.
Story and characters are the best parts of VA.
I think, you know, obviously the characters are very cute,
but the story is really interesting.
It's got a really great blend of humor and seriousness and
emotional.
Like, you really become attached to the characters.
They make it really easy.
It's...
There's mystery.
It's a little creepy.
Sometimes it's a little creepy, no?
Like, there's just some mysterious...
aspect.
So, it's very fun.
So, you know, I even if you're just like, I don't do gotcha
games, even if you're not into, like, you know, the gotcha
aspect of it all.
The story itself, I mean, you just need to have the game for
that.
So it's very, very fun.
And then of course, cute girls.
The story ties them all together.
Bounce a comedy and drama is just perfect.
Agreed, agreed, agreed, agreed.
Yeah.
So, I just got back into BA yesterday.
Welcome back, Sensei!
Welcome back.
Yes.
Read Haruka's mini-story for good luck.
I do want to go through, where was it?
Yeah, the new mini-story, right?
This one.
We'll go through this one later.
Weeds don't grow alone.
Maybe this will be it.
This will be the luck we need.
No.
No spoilers, obviously, but Volume 3 is still one of my...
Yes.
Honestly, anything with, like, the tree...
Okay, wait.
Okay, hold on.
Oh.
Yes.
But today, we will be doing Chapter 2.
of X-Lore Pursuit.
Which is very cool.
It's about the Fox Squad.
Here, I'll just read the little sample here.
The little summary.
The unexplainable abnormalities that have been popping up
across Kivotos.
Lore.
Will the Fox Squad be able to restore their everyday lives
and rescue the students who have vanished?
But yeah, the Fox Squad.
This one was really fun.
The High Noon Haze.
It's about like a...
creepy scarecrow spooky scarecrow spooky scarecrow and um
it's kind of like ghost stories we're doing at the moment so
yeah the kune kune was very creepy creepy scarecrow feels
redundant okay are you a crow are you okay can't go into any
go into any farms huh you all you all right
fox squad is very cute i like nico a lot i think she's very
cute um you know i i'm a big fan of the rabbit squad squad
squad squad squad squad too so um you know having the both
of them uh is fun giant i know she's got such good ears
I can never get any cord anymore I know right you just you
can't go out pick your crops what are you gonna do is too
scared of scarecrows but let's um they don't want it they
want me to go through a few of the chapters of the or the
episodes I mean so sorry if I get terminology wrong my brain
is always like it's it's act this chapter this episode this
it's kind of like that way they have it separated so yeah so
oh my gosh wait I'm gonna be like voice acting for you guys
they we're gonna try and go through episodes 1 through 4 we
might kind of skip through a few of them so that we can get
at least to episode 4 but yeah let's get into it resentment
is not to be released yummy Yummy pyros.
Yeah, you get pyros just for reading, you guys, so you can
do the gotcha.
Isn't it amazing?
What are they crazy?
Yeah, they gotta be.
That's it.
It's a joke.
The music in this game.
I love this one.
So good.
This is so creepy.
No sane person would ever do something like that.
I'll admit, I was a little late on a few payments.
I would have got the money.
But all that...
Over a little pocket change?
Come on, have a heart!
Pocket change, is it?
Ooh, mystery.
Sure, it might not seem like a lot of money to most people.
But you're the one running because of it, so perhaps it is
substantial.
Eek!
I'm sorry!
What I meant to say was...
Please, don't apologize.
It doesn't matter if he meant it or not, we've heard enough
from you.
We are the ones who need to send a message.
That all starts with making an example of a certain scumbag
who thought he could run off with our money.
We got the helmet, gang.
What other thing that I like about Blue Archive is even like
the background characters, the NPCs, if you will, they're so
cute.
And goofy and fun.
By making an example, you don't mean with...
Ah, so you're familiar.
Good, I wasn't in the mood for explaining.
Mob chance, yeah?
See, you're going to get very acquainted with your new best
friends.
They've made dinner plans with you.
At the bottom of this drum barrel.
What?
And they're positively famished.
They're going to enjoy every...
Last bite.
How long will you last, I wonder?
I'm going to turn it up a little bit.
Sleeping with the fishes.
Wait!
No, this can't be real.
It's impossible!
Are the monster crabs everyone's been talking about actually
real?
They're not supposed to be able to...
Who knows?
I'm not a biologist.
So let's find out together.
Right now.
Please, just a little more time.
A week a day.
Hope I triple.
No five times what you want.
I swear I'll do anything.
Oh, he's shivering.
Just don't put me in the barrel.
Oh, no.
To be continued.
No way.
That's the first episode?
Poor guy.
Crab and fish meat sausage.
Let's go.
Fox 2, Fox 3, reporting back.
Heya!
Oh, nice job.
But why are you so late?
You...
Those ears.
I know, look how cute they are.
Did you run into issues at the Valkyrie Records archives?
Kurumi is very cute, too.
Gosh, they're all cute.
No, the infiltration was flawless.
Her security bureau badges and student IDs were absolutely
identical.
But then some public safety bureau students started
eyeballing us on our way out.
She was kind of blocking the door.
I guess she had sharp eyes from the way she was staring at
us.
She was clearly thinking something.
Wait, the security bureau caught you?
Nah, Nico threw her off and started gushing about our team.
He's an old doughnut.
Naturally, I had to commit.
We ended up in line at Master's doughnuts.
Yeah!
You guys meet up, Sensei meet up at Master's doughnuts after
this?
Go Shujin-sama?
To try their limited edition release.
The line wrapped around the block.
So that's why we're late.
Sorry about that.
Don't be sorry.
Good work.
I know.
Hey, where's Yukino?
Bondering.
She's still meeting with the General Student Council
President.
I wish to talk about this, but I don't want to...
I wish to speak about this.
Let's... I don't want spoilers.
No, talk, talk.
I know.
what you mean so much oh yeah wink wonk yeah she's very cute
and nothing malicious yeah no so like I said there's kind of
a mystery how I don't want to say because it's kind of like
crazy you know ah you guys just have to play and and you
guys just all have to play so that we can talk okay you guys
just everybody has to play and catch up on the story okay
very sus we are in a very sus part of the story for sure i
mean things are things have been suspicious in in kivoto's
but right now it is i'm like my eyes are like i'm like and
she said she'd eat over there so we shouldn't wait up oh
togi you haven't had dinner yet you must be hungry i'll make
you something hold on I'm fine, I've been snacking on this.
This and that.
Yokozuna's crab and fish meat sausage?
You're really into that, aren't you?
Well, it's convenient.
Has a long shelf life and I only need one to feel full.
And most importantly, I like how it hardly has a smell.
It's silent, too.
It's the best choice for a sniper.
No, an assassin.
One who it must always eat in secret.
Undetected.
Is she eating...
It's people!
No.
Was that supposed to be an impression of someone?
You're not fine.
No matter how convenient some meat stick is, I can't let you
skip a meal.
You're still growing, so you need to eat properly.
Miko mama.
Wait here.
I'll make you some food.
Yes, ma'am.
By the way, wouldn't a fish sausage...
Sausage is so hard to say.
Fish sausage.
I keep going fish sausage.
Be super expensive if it's made with crab.
Are you cutting into the ammo budget to buy yourself snacks?
No.
This isn't even expensive.
It's less than 100 yen a pop.
Dang!
Oh, the sponsor's saying...
No!
A cheap can of crab corn.
cost 1000 yen and you're saying that crab meat sausage
doesn't even have a even cost a tenth of that let me see
fish sauce fish sauce this isn't real crab meat this is crab
meat flavored fish sausage look at the ingredients contains
less than 1% crab oh oh no that's like when I get the juice
and it's like 3% juice and you're like oh man They're lying
to you.
They just sprayed crab essence or whatever on some cheap
fish paste.
I can't believe it.
Yokozuna's crab and fish meat sausage doesn't use real crab?
My world's falling apart!
Don't be so dramatic.
You should have known when you saw how cheap it was.
Ever heard the saying, there's no such thing as a free
lunch.
My favorite game, crab meat discussion.
I know, this is making me hungry, even if it's not even real
crumb.
Speaking of seafood, I heard our juniors in the Rabbit
Squad.
Yay, Rabbit Squad mentioned!
Helped people in a nearby fishing village.
They were rewarded with premium shrimp.
Oh, yeah!
When was this?
We were locked up in the corrections bureau at the time.
You guys, if you don't know the story...
It's, uh...
It's been a...
A lot has happened.
But you see, D-U's shrimp supply was suddenly cut off.
No, I'm not talking about the shrimp.
Nico, were you talking to our juniors?
You didn't tell us?
A lot has happened.
That's not fair.
I wanted to see them, too.
I didn't plan for it to be this way.
You know the Corrections Bureau doesn't allow us to have
personal phones.
I was just replying to letters that Miyako sent.
casual and sporadic at first, but we became pet pals.
Yeah, they're kind of on parole.
Ah, makes sense.
Miyako is so earnest.
Imagine sitting down and actually writing a letter.
She should be in my cafe.
What are you doing?
Yeah, it's one of her consistent strengths.
And it's a frequent weakness, too.
She's known to take her earnestness to her.
too far.
Jorama.
Parole patrol?
Yeah.
Of course.
Right.
I suppose you can't take the good without the bad.
I'm jealous of their shrimp, though.
Maybe we should solve some crab-related mystery.
We might get a few good meals out of it.
What kind of twisted wish is that?
Hoping for an incident just because you have a craving?
I was kidding.
Spare me the glare.
Look, now I just want some crab.
Not canned, not sausage, but real crab.
Yukino, welcome back.
Crab.
I caught him to be yesterday on a whim.
The stars are aligned.
Let's go!
Welcome, Sensei.
Welcome.
What?
We're taking on a crab.
Yeah!
Crab!
The crab in the drum barrel!
Let's go.
Let's watch.
Crab, you say.
Yes.
Crab's known for their hard shells.
Wide set eyes and clacking claws.
Have you ever seen a live crab, Yukino?
I guess maybe here it would be kind of...
I have.
Maybe it would be...
I like money.
Yeah, I've seen crap.
Yeah, I watched... I watched Bebob.
Duh.
Sorry, sponsored stream.
When the training in the summer, we passed through the
mudflats.
I used to see crabs scuttling along in groups.
Mudflats.
Sounds intriguing.
That's our...
Student Council...
President, everybody!
I've been so busy with the general student council I can't
even remember the last time I went to the beach There she is
She's totally back
That sounds rough But why did you suddenly bring up crabs?
I thought we were discussing missing persons cases Well,
Yukino, they're related Oh, I love the crustacean period.
Are the chief suspects behind these disappearances?
I don't understand.
How are you guys appreciating my voice acting?
Am I doing a good job?
Aruna, help!
Aruna, help us!
An increasing number of people have gone missing near
Kanesaki Port.
We can't tell whether these are just simple fall accidents.
People intentionally going into hiding or something more.
Multiple people have posted online, claiming that they've
seen the infamous drum barrel...
I can't speak.
Drum barrel crabs at the port.
Yukino.
Can the Fox Squad investigate this?
I want everything you can find on the drum barrel crabs.
You need to close your nose.
My bad.
Drum barrel crabs.
Yes, it started with a gruesome urban legend.
Imagine an orial drum filled with hundreds of scuttling
crabs.
The crabs inside the barrel are said to be so ferocious and
famished that they can strip the meat off of a board and
then break that down too.
Say drum barrel crabs three times fast.
Drum barrel crabs, drum barrel crabs, drum barrel crabs.
Drum barrel, drum barrel crab, drum barrel crab, drum barrel
crab.
what is it what is the the crab the bucket crab theory or
not theory but like saying you know where crabs will like
try to climb out and the other crabs will drag them back in
quab yeah crabs in a bucket yeah yeah this that but crabs in
a barrel and they're hungry you are not a crab and they are
Most rumors affiliated with the drum barrel crabs tend to be
simple as well.
Most notably, people say that disgruntled fishermen at
Kanesaki Port are known to fill a drum barrel with crabs
when they harbor a grudge.
Then they take someone to a secluded spot and throw them
into the barrel filled with the chittering crabs.
And the victims vanishes without a trace.
Whoa, the perfect crime.
What a creepy urban legend.
what do you well obviously we have the anime but i want my
sensei to sound kind of silly sensei are you serious an
ordinary crab can't even scratch a person let alone hurt
them that's not true oh you have never been pitched by a
crab crabs aren't hunters they're scavengers they use their
claws to shred dead fish and pick seaweed that is such a lie
also crab shells are thinner and more brittle than you might
think.
Their shells can only get so thick because they have to
molt.
They're literally not built to last.
It would be gross, but you could crack a crab just by
knocking it.
If the person in the drum barrel struggled, the crabs would
squish first, like a bunch of bugs.
Their claws are relatively hard, but human bones are
tougher.
An ordinary crab can only grow up to about 25 centimeters.
If you want a crab with claws powerful enough It'd have to
be at least five meters long, I'd say.
We are discussing the practicalities of a human body
squishing crabs before the crabs can squish you.
What do you mean?
What are they talking about?
Uh, duh.
These are in the important conversations of life.
It would have to be at least 20 meters wide.
Well, that's a relief to hear.
So how do you know so much about crabs?
I don't think Otoki's crab math is correct.
What?
She's not a marine biologist, you guys.
The true cute girls doing cute things experience.
Yes, of course.
Have you not ever watched A Slice of Life and they just talk
about anything random?
This is quite literally a slice of life conversation.
I met someone on a maritime salvage mission.
We had lots of time to talk.
For me, it's from experience.
They are a delicious ingredient, after all.
I was working undercover at a sushi restaurant.
The chef was eager to share.
Even if we're not dealing with a giant crab that's attacking
people, it's evident that someone is using these crab rumors
to turn a profit It's also clear that people went missing in
Kanesaki port.
The public's found out, thinks these two incidents are
related, and believes that this crab story is true.
So why would someone spread such a sloppy urban legend like
this?
If anyone thinks for a few seconds, they'll see that it's
impossible.
Are they trying to pin their crimes on a crab or something?
No one wants to deal with a monster crab that attacks
people.
If someone were to exploit that fear...
What if someone's gaming the system?
They're trying to tank the crab market by making them sound
scary and unapotizing.
Mary time.
Ooh, la la.
We'll kick off this investigation by focusing on the
merchants profiting from the price drop.
I'm not seeing any recent fluctuations in crab prices.
Maybe it's because the rumor hasn't spread yet.
Duh, this is weak.
Not enough for a conclusion.
special work I'd still eat the crabs yeah put throw me in
coach I got this probably yes there's only so much we can
deduce from the armchair in these times rather than making
wild speculations we should carefully collect information is
that what you meant yes our destination D Yu Shiro Tori City
4th Avenue Kanesaki port our suspects everyone in the crabic
industry.
Oh gosh, all crab all crabbies, crabbers, everybody who
touches a crab, deals with crab.
Get out of here.
You're a suspect.
First an overpass, and now we're investigating a port.
At least there should be plenty of shade.
I'm sick of worrying about heatstroke.
That was the previous mission they did.
Ready yourself, Fox Squad, are investigating.
has begun.
Crabs, crabs, crab, crabbologists, yeah.
People of the poor.
Alright, we're gonna go through this one.
And then continue onward.
Jamming out.
So cute.
Helmet gang.
Don't mind me.
Just fox delivery.
Grub!
Yeah, we got a cute little cutscene.
What?
This is so fun!
Oh wait, we're doing field exploration, no way!
So sometimes, that's one thing I forgot to mention earlier.
Is like, there's, you know, there's obviously the visual
novel aspects of the story, but sometimes you kind of, like,
run around and, like, talk to different students, and you
can, um, like, there's even mini-games, like, Blue Archive
has so much.
you know like it's kind of crazy yeah
they've been to great appeal and exploration in the story
now so fun so fun all right this is Fox 1 Fox 2 have you
successfully breached the target location affirmative Fox 2
here I've entered point alpha no trouble confirmed so far
continuing with the mission Fox 3 speaking at point, Sierra,
with Fox 4.
We have good visuals on the target location.
No problems here, either.
I was so worried when you got stopped at the checkpoint, Fox
2.
You've definitely handled the security guards, Fox 2.
You really do seem like a delivery worker.
I hope so.
I want people to believe I'm really here from Fox Eats after
all.
Fox 1.
Who's our first target?
Her latest missing person is one Miyaguchi.
He is young and supposedly works on a crabbing boat.
He was last seen at our mission point, Kanesaki Port.
Fox eat!
Though he hasn't been in the fishing industry that long, he
is known for his lavish spending and constant complaining.
He's been in a few scraps and rumor has it that he also has
accrued some heavy debt.
Debt and conflicts.
here private loans are a shortcut to trouble you should all
be careful when dealing with credit transactions why is she
looking at me yes ma'am yes ma'am she's she's she's talking
through the screen also isn't my hair cut kind of of similar
to Nico's maybe we should I don't know maybe I should grow
some Fox ears or she should grow some loops Fox
4 do you read huh why am I being singled out because you buy
ammo on credit sometimes and also don't you remember that
time when you forgot your payment deadline and ordered an an
expensive handguard?
Hold on, that was forever ago!
I'm not familiar.
Can you tell me more, Fox 3?
Now's not the time to reminisce.
We should focus on the mission!
Please grow giant fox ears, Minto.
Okay, I'll do my best.
She's right.
Fox 2, I'll continue with the briefing.
Got it.
For now.
Ugh!
According to this fellow fisherman, Miyaguchi suddenly
disappeared a week ago, after departing a docked fishing
boat.
He seemingly evaporated into thin air, leaving his
belongings and clothes behind on the ship.
So, only the other fishermen saw him disembark, right?
Yes.
So remember that any fisherman you meet is a potential
suspect.
Proceed cautiously and avoid suspicion.
My specialty!
We love Foxgirls here.
Foxgirl, Foxgirl, Foxgirl!
A fox, ghost, yokai.
I mean, ghost is basically a yokai too.
So what if I...
It could be fine to transform into other types of yokai,
maybe.
Or I could just possess a fox, right?
So where can I find those fishermen?
There's a crabbing boat moored up here three, south side.
They should be managing their fishing gear around this time.
They might have space to talk.
Okay, then I'm off.
Yippee!
Oh my gosh!
Wow!
He's so cute!
Mmm, squid.
Crab catchers.
Alright, investigate the circumstances around the missing...
Missing?
Fisherman.
According to the information, the missing fisherman worked
on a crab fishing boat.
It is possible that his crewmates may know more.
Oh!
There's too much to do.
I can help with that.
Look how cute.
Oh!
Young people these days.
It's almost lunch time.
Food?
I want to eat something hardy.
Talk to me.
Kitty!
No one here seems suspicious.
Nope, not me.
Not me for sure.
Oh, I'm like going way off.
Alright, let's see who we can talk to.
They're all so cute, right?
Wow, cute the birds!
Hello, hello, hello.
Don't mind me.
What you saying?
Oh, hello, hello?
You can pet the cat.
Wait.
can you that's a very important oh
wait oh
baby oh my god I miss my cat johnny
ow 10 out of 10 game for real okay sorry little guy we gotta
get go out
To be too.
Oh.
Too cute.
What's going on in here?
Hmm.
With all the trash picked up, it looks so much better.
Yes, yes.
Oh.
Oh, I don't want to get in the way of their work.
Oh, my bad.
Okay.
This way.
Oh.
I must resist urge to pet second cat.
Touch fluffy tail?
No, pet second cat.
Look how cute.
Oh, we're over here.
Even just like here, being here is a vibe.
How?
Oh, don't mind me.
Don't mind.
Area head is off limits.
Are you sure you're not lost?
Uh...
Do you know anything, mister?
Ah, here we go.
Um, excuse me.
I wanted to ask you something.
You can sit on the bench.
We will.
Not very talkative.
Oh.
What should I do?
I don't think they want to talk.
Oh, I'm getting a...
I'm going to...
Hello?
Moshi-moshi?
Fox 2, is there a problem?
Oh, sorry, wait.
Oh, yeah.
It looks like you're floundering around.
You need to talk to people.
Well, the fishermen are a little...
Cold.
Szemitai!
They don't answer me.
They just walk away.
Do you think they're onto us?
No way.
It's not like we're openly and terribly...
eating people.
It could be that they just don't like outsiders.
Mobius 1, Fox 2.
We're not floundering.
We're crabbing!
Duh.
Maybe they're just introverted.
Well, what should we do if we can't get them to talk in the
first place?
And it's not like we can take them in for questioning.
Plus two, thank you.
Don't worry.
This is why I prepared Fox Eats.
Would you like some fox eats?
They look so grumpy.
Excuse me!
Why are you yelling?
I almost dropped the tool!
I'm sorry, I was just so excited because I have such big
news to share!
Huh?
Big news?
Yes, lunch was hours ago and you've been working the whole
time!
You must be hungry!
which is why Fox Eats prepared a special promotion just for
you if you participate in a short survey from Fox Eats right
now you'll get a complimentary bento from Yoshino in
Inaizushi real eat real needle with Yoshido my brain oh my
goodness all you need to do is answer a couple questions
just a few minutes and you'll earn a free bento instantly Oh
my gosh, I gotta become a fisherman.
Something's fishy.
Yeah, they say nothing's free in this world.
You're up to something, aren't you?
Uh, it's not free.
You have to answer a survey.
Duh.
Not at all.
Naturally, there are a few minor conditions.
This survey is used by Fox Eats to improve product and
services.
And survey results may be shared to third parties for
promotion of...
Oh my gosh, you're getting the fine print.
Survey results will be retained for 36 months.
For any inquiries, please contact Foxy.
It's a customer service to- Stop!
I get it!
I got it!
Based on the way she rattled that off, it looks like some
upstart marketing firms burning through their money again.
The terms and conditions.
That said, she mentioned free food.
And I just so happen to be hungry.
Let's see.
Mm-hmm.
Huh?
This is...
Now that's some good inari-zushi.
Oh, I love inari-zushi.
Maybe I am a fox girl after all.
I love inari-zushi.
The rice has great texture and the fried tofu is just the
right thickness.
No more words, give food, but stew.
Ah, is something bothering you?
Your honest feedback is incredibly helpful.
Fox Eats always seeks to improve our service.
So please share your honest opinion.
Did they put a crab stick in here?
It's a bit of a shame that they sullied such delicious tofu
with fake crab meat.
Huh?
I thought that was common.
Isn't genuine crab prohibi-prohibit-prohibit-pro-
prohibitively?
Expensive?
From what I heard, crab is a luxury.
i heard it's so pricey that a single crab would cost my
whole day's wage
that's old news kid crab prices are way down like on the
ocean floor yeah their prices are so low that we're
considering cutting back our fishing rights we've barely
made enough to cover the cost of fuel is that so but it
feels like crab is always so expensive at the market that's
a store this is the real world If you're so skeptical, take
a look in that warehouse.
You'll find a mountain of unsold crab.
I see.
I understand.
I'll make sure your feedback reaches...
The restaurant.
Oh, this reminds me.
Since you all work here, I'm curious.
Have you heard of something like, Crab's in a drum barrel
before?
Crab's in a drum barrel.
Are there people who deliver crabs in a drum barrel?
I don't know about other places, but we send our crabs out
in wooden crates.
Look in the warehouse.
You'll see.
Why did she say it like that?
Interesting.
Thank you for participating in the survey.
Have a wonderful afternoon.
It seems the fishermen haven't heard of the rumors.
It didn't seem like they were lying.
If the crabbing has been good, why would someone spread
rumors about... Oh, first let's go check out the warehouse.
Okay.
I missed that.
Oh, we got a new little thingy.
The fruit link, the fruit link.
This is, this is like a new, it's like a, it's, it's like a,
I mean, it says it, local hub for reporting and researching
lore and urban legends.
Doesn't Kani also mean money and crab?
You're thinking of Kane, which means money, but you're very
close.
It seems like the crab harvest is so big this year because
of the hot weather.
My uncle, who's a fisherman.
said it's actually better to not go crabbing at all because
the prices drop so low really the wire crab is still
expensive at the grocery store in my house it's all a
conspiracy from the general student council they're
deliberately manipulating the prices to prevent ordinary
citizens from accumulating wealth please sub sub to fact
channel do these delivery services promote restaurants now I
just got some inari sushi from a part-time delivery like how
is this profitable oh my gosh romantic fisher which one do
you think i think it was the pup oh yeah and then we got or
this is uh don't worry about that guy okay crab catchers
complete the missing sawdust all right help the worker by
looking for the bag of sawdust i didn't know that sawdust
was necessary to preserve crab may have thought it was
trash, so perhaps we could check the dump site.
Was the dump site the place over here?
The one that they said they cleaned up all the trash?
Bro has become a TV!
He has!
Wait, this is a dump site, no?
Well, there's lots of crates here.
Oh!
I found it.
Hello!
This is not good.
Hey.
I know what I said, but don't say it.
I said pervert.
Ah!
Who moved around the supplies without getting approval?
Whoopsie.
Oh, no.
There's our girl.
I don't want to get... Yeah, yeah.
Sorry.
You.
Excuse me.
Yeah.
What do you want?
Greetings.
From bento delivery to restaurant reservations.
Fox Eats is your way stop service agency anytime you'll get
the grumblies we've just expanded our delivery service to
include cousin Kanesaki port to celebrate this we're
offering the local community complimentary bento boxes would
you like to take a short break and enjoy some delicious
inari sushi I'm I am interested but I can't afford to be
taking a break right now Minto eats you want to try my
cooking you want to my cooking?
I am not a maid of the kitchen.
Oh dear, is something going on?
Well, have you seen a loose sack of sawdust by any chance?
A sack of dust?
Dau-Dau-Sus.
Wait.
Dau-S- Yeah.
You see, this is why I don't do visual though.
It's bag shaped and filled with sand like scrap so you get
after a woodworking.
I need it to stack the crabs in the boxes.
We use the sawdust to pack them in.
Nice and secure.
But I guess someone walked off with it.
I can't work without it.
She can't work under these conditions, you guys.
Just let me know if you find an abandoned sawdust sack.
Oh, I said it.
fresh.
It's really important.
Got it.
If I see an abandoned sawdust sack, you'll be the first to
know.
S-s-s-s-s-sack.
A sack full of sawdust.
Oh my gosh.
It's heavy, so whoever took it couldn't have gone far.
Maybe someone saw- oh no!
Oh no!
It's triggering my my stuttered.
Ah!
Okay, they couldn't have gone far, right?
Oh.
This is our territory!
My bad.
I'm just looking for some dust.
I'm looking for some dust.
Made of...
Is this it?
Does that not look like it?
Looks like a sack, indeed.
The girls be laughing.
The dust of saw.
They couldn't have gotten far.
It looked like it, no!
He's feeding the fish's dust.
Hmm.
Probably, maybe, maybe down here?
Anybody?
No?
Um...
As we sit, if I were a bag of dust, where would I be?
Inari sushi.
Itadakimasu!
Oh, ishi.
You're the wood chipper.
Oh, ishi!
Oh, my!
Okay, that's all for now.
So cute!
So freaking cute!
Oh, it's so cute!
Ah, it was much closer than I...
Oh!
I was right, just wrong location.
They couldn't look around the corner.
Pet the cat, we already did!
I should go back and tell the workers where the...
Yeah, where it's at.
Um...
Aren't you the delivery student from earlier?
Did you find that missing... stuff?
Yes, it was in a vacant alley with some other supplies.
If I were to guess, maybe someone thought it was a trash
bag.
There were a few in the area right over there.
Really?
That's a relief.
Thank you so much.
We were worried that we'd have to throw out all these crabs.
You're a lifesaver.
Not at all.
I'm just glad to help.
By the way, why are crabs packed in sawdust?
It sounds rather dry.
Wood powdery.
It's for transportation.
Crabs are weak to shock.
Even with these hard shells, the slightest shaker bump can
kill a crab.
So that's why we spread a thick layer of sawdust around
them.
It cushions their shells and absorbs shock.
And you have a point.
We wet it too.
Since sod dust also retains moisture, it's even better for
transporting crabs.
Keeps them relatively comfortable in all that.
Is this real?
Do they actually transport crabs like this?
I see.
How fascinating.
You wash shop.
All right.
By the way, have you ever heard of transporting crabs in a
drum barrel?
Crabs in a drum barrel?
I've never heard of it before.
Oh, really?
I wonder why.
It seems much more stable than a crate.
that might be but drum barrels are way too heavy the higher
the weight the will higher the shipping costs so there's no
reason to use a drum barrel instead of a cheap wooden crate
don't you think I don't know why this this accent is coming
out on top of that if you pack a drum barrel with crabs the
air wouldn't circulate the ones at the bottom would
suffocate brutal I see after hearing that sounds like the
story of crabs in a drum barrel is something only a person
ignorant of the biology of crabs would believe aren't they
freeze instantly are they no some crabs are like this wow
are you seriously telling beat me people out there gossiping
about crab logistics they must just they I guess they must
be bored.
Everyone has different interests after all.
Oh right, I almost forgot.
As a token of appreciation for your fascinating... well,
your insightful story.
I'd like to offer you this Inari-zushi bento from Yoshino
Inari-zushi.
It's a huge hit on Foxeats.
I couldn't possibly.
How can I take food from you when you were the one who all
in sawdust?
all part of the job ma'am think of it as a special promotion
if anything you could leave a positive review on social
media and tag us it mean the world sorry that there's two
missing I got hungry of course I will thank you so much it
looks great have a nice day so I do it the accent gets
stronger with every line
Oh yeah, yeah, thank you for kind of explaining the halos a
little bit.
This is Fox 1, Fox 2, status report requested.
Fox 2 here.
The targets are extremely on guard, so I'm prioritizing
building report.
I've been casually discussing the crabs in a drum barrel
story, but it seems unfamiliar to the local populace.
Are they playing dumb?
always possible but most people working at the port seem to
think that putting crabs in a drum barrel was pointless so
if the culprit wanted to intimidate the locals at the port
then they should have come up with a better story that's
very astute these people know too much they would never
spread the drum barrel crab rumor because they know it
doesn't make sense where's a my halo I'm already dead
doesn't does that conclude today's investigation I'm
thinking of asking around the industrial district we have
some time Fox 3 with no objections we have a nice breeze
going I can last a little longer no objections from Fox 4
either I'll keep eyes on the poor affirmative Fox 2 move to
point Charlie and continue the mission there Fox 2 Roger
that consider the Ahoye as a halo sure sure oh my gosh sorry
I got I've got to go online, though.
Why are crabs such weaklings?
They die from even the slightest shock.
And even the ones that do survive often lose their legs and
most their worth.
The hard shell is useless.
Yippee!
Alrighty.
I do probably have to wrap it up soon, though.
Because we gotta...
Guys, we gotta finish a couple stuff.
We gotta do...
Okay.
I do have to finish up.
Sorry.
I might have to...
No!
I have to skip it, I think!
We gotta get through more of the story.
No!
I just realized.
Oh, man.
Come on now!
I'm way behind.
I got too into it.
How did the polls go?
We're about to go do some more.
I'm back!
Here.
sorry we have to we have to skip sorry we're skipping the
reflection i
got too invested good to see you sensei and great work today
thank you so much for your help saying to you nico that's
right we all went to the port to investigate the rumors we
were talking about yesterday we heard so many stories about
port life and crabs would you mind helping us organize them
of course looks like everyone's here let's proceed with our
mission reports we'll summary right yeah if you want to see
more play the game look how cute they are we did the what's
the common perception what was this i saw some tourists on
the port they weren't fishers or locals and they were
talking about this urban legend very seriously some were put
off by crab claws or shells and some seriously believe that
crap so this is the part that we missed believe that crabs
were attacking people how can such a ridiculous urban legend
spread like this If they kept up with the news, or if they
even looked this up online, they would see it's a bald-faced
lie.
People don't put much interest in rumors that don't directly
affect their lives.
Unfortunately, you guys, I am one ghost.
So many lines to read all by myself.
I wanted to hear more of these accent.
A serious problem for those up close is nothing more than
entertainment to those watching from afar.
And let's face it, a spicy lie is much more interesting than
a dull reality.
A single light can spread a rumor to dozens or even hundreds
of people before anyone gets it in a proper word.
How bleak.
In conclusion, the reason why people believe that killer
crabs are real is because...
Because it's actually happening.
It's because they're being hypnotized.
The rumor is being spread by the ignorant.
Right, this rumor involves Kanesaki Port.
But only the people who took it seriously were tourists.
They didn't know anything about crabbing industry.
Look at us, we're such sleuths, we're such detectives.
That's how the rumors spread so much.
The people who shared it didn't even know that the story
made no sense.
Always double check what you read online, everybody.
Kuzunoha even has a saying.
Don't trust the quote next to the photo.
I find that quote to be very questionable.
Check your sources, everyone.
this rest yeah all righty next episode records of fear we
will actually be doing uh five episodes five and six or
attempting to get as much as we can um um oh i'm being told
though that episode six is quite lengthy though so we'll do
we'll do our best But, but, before we get to five and six,
we have to go do more recruiting!
This time, though, we're trying for Haruka.
Hopefully, after a nice little break, we, uh, we'll, we'll,
right?
I would like to get both of them.
I would, all right, hold on.
I don't care I don't care I don't care I don't care
sorry I got so shocked that it took off my cardigan it
knocked my it knocked my clothes off if
you notice tears running down my face you don't if
you think you see tears you actually don't it's okay it's
okay it could switch it could switch is it raining is it
raining it has
to be it this is it this is it
This is okay.
I want Megutrade, please.
Of course.
I also want to see...
I want to see Plana and Arona together.
Every time we've seen Plana, it hasn't been...
No, three-star student.
Plana, I love you, but do you love me?
It's not mint over.
I don't care.
Oh, Shibiko!
Let's go.
I'm so cool and calm and collected.
Plana.
Plana, I think you hate me.
I think you hate me.
Oh!
I got armed Amy!
I don't care.
This is me not caring.
I care!
Please take some of my Groucho lock.
My streamer lock, what has happened?
What has happened?
This is what my pulls usually look like off-stream, you
guys.
The desire sensor can't be fooled.
We have 33 more tentacles, you guys.
Plana.
Chinatsu?
Okay, have you guys ever seen Chinatsu's hot spring, like,
full image?
It's so funny because her...
Her, her, like, you know, if you ever see, like, her acrylic
stand, it's ginormous.
It's humongous because they include the entire, like, hot
spring.
It's so funny.
Oh, I'm feeling... Good about this one!
Ah!
head patlob oh my god it's
okay we got to see the animation it was so cute i'm sorry
here's our last one everybody
I actually didn't see what uh let's see a hard look deals
1,245% of attack is damage to what enemy ignores.
60% of enemy defense.
Deals 6.8% of...
Thank you.
I was sending you plenty of energy, I swear.
I know you were.
I know.
Increases attack every 35 seconds.
Recover is 120% healing.
Okay.
I'm trying to decide why.
This is... yeah, I just increased attack.
accumulates one I won't forgive you upon taking damage each
stack of I won't forgive you increase this crit damage by
10% that's kind of it's such a funny like such a funny um
description oh we saw we saw Mutsuki
Increase attack.
Increase his crit damage res of enemies in circular area.
I love Haruka but Dress Mutsuki has some peak momos.
Okay, we'll go for Mutsuki then.
Increase his attack of user and special students.
By 27%.
So cute!
I mean look at that memorial!
It's so cute!
This is so cute!
Oh my gosh, I watered her on the couch.
Live 3D was enough for me to pull her.
I know!
Haruka is still very cute too.
They're all great, great students.
Everybody is a good student.
But we, I think, Mutsuki might make for some more
interesting Momos.
collect you.
Oh,
guys, we got her!
Oh my god!
Yeah!
Oh, yeah, we got her!
Oh!
I for sure, I was like, we're gonna get both today.
It'll be so awesome.
And then I'll throw them both into my, uh, into my cafe.
Yeah.
First try, first try.
But that's okay.
We can throw her in.
I thought so too, but got the same life.
That's just the way the cookie grumbles.
Congrats on getting Dress Mutsuki in a single pull.
What luck?
I know, crazy, right?
Hold on, let me see again.
Mutsuki unlocks at Bond 5.
Okay, awesome.
Let's just, I've been saving up.
Do I have, I have my, I'll give her my AX pass.
Wait, what is she, what does Mutsuki like?
Um...
What does she like?
Wait, actually I can go to her, can't I?
Where'd she go?
Wait, where'd she go?
Oh wait, oh yeah, she's gonna be higher.
I forgot I unlocked her.
There she is.
Uh...
button I think did I have that oh okay the fake glasses okay
okay awesome
oh I have eight of them let's go
I'll just give like one more wait what did she do there was
like there was like flowers around her and stuff look how
cute it is oh she's so cute oh she's so cute okay yeah it
shows how much they like it yeah yeah okay let's see well
that was um that was fine that was fine let's go back to the
story and then gonna do the the the side story the mini
story where the where it shows them all in their dresses so
you can see all of problem-solver 68 looking lovely for the
night will we go back here and
we're back inside chapter 2 records of fear unfortunately
we'll probably have to skip through quite a bit of this oh
why is it so scary excuse me how I wanted to look up a
newspaper clipping in the reading room.
Was the morning paper from Oh Old Not Clipped?
Looks like that specific day is missing from the scrapbook.
How odd.
I clip the articles every morning, so nothing should be
missing.
I remember it now.
Someone from the publisher came and collected the newspapers
that evening.
They said they needed to make a correction.
It's rare for them to repossess their papers, so I remember
that tonight clearly.
I see.
Do you remember what the correction was about?
No, I'm paid to clip.
Not to read.
I'm sorry.
There were so many articles.
I simply don't remember.
I see.
Thank you for your help.
Creepy.
An effective suppression of information.
That's why most people thought that weird bird monster was
nothing more than a silly story.
I was among them until recently.
Let's get this straight, Sensei.
This limited edition plushed name Per- Perro- Perrozilla
came to life because of fans' obsessive desires.
Then it approached the DU and was defeated in a joint
operation with Shale and Valkyrie.
You know, the Valkyrie System Bureau records we procured a
mention to large deployment.
Perro- Perro-Zilla.
I'm gonna say it.
say it.
I'm going to be brave.
Yeah, it comes back every few months.
Peronodzilla.
Peronol.
I want to punch that thing.
I'm going to say it.
I want to punch Peronol.
Since Sensei attested to it, there must be must have been a
monster attacking the coast that day.
But something's bothering.
me.
Why did the monster take the form of that goofy-looking bird
in the first place?
Don't let Hifumi here.
I know.
Yeah, Hifumi, cover your ears.
I want to punch it.
And I want to take her pedo-do stuff and step on it.
Say it with your chest.
I'll say it.
I'll say it once, I'll say it again.
in the minds of the masses would be terrifying.
Unfortunately, though, we do kind of probably have to rush
things a little bit, so I'm going to...
Let's see.
Yukino visits the municipal library to search Pedro
Godzilla.
Any and all articles have been redacted.
Redacted!
I've been playing other games that have many redacted
things.
But Yukino, with Shimiko's help, uncovers a trail.
We won't skip, skip, but we'll kind of just kind of...
It doesn't add up.
specific book you're looking for?
No, it's not a book.
I can help you with whatever you need.
After all, it's a librarian's duty to aid those in search of
knowledge.
Who could this silhouette be?
Of course, while I might not be here.
Ta-da!
We might have it in our library.
Our library.
Allow me to introduce myself.
I'm Endo Shimiko!
Oh!
Yeah!
You guys might recognize the artist maybe.
I work at the Trinity Library Committee, but I'm here today
for a book exchange event.
So Shimiko is going to help us out.
Thank you, Shimiko.
The shadow is as big as a whale, but as fast as a Marlin.
helicopters in the operation crazy article mentioned that
you couldn't get that Momo friends plushie anymore thank you
that was very helpful but it's surprising and I expect to
run into a librarian who remembers the details of a random
newspaper article do you have a photographic memory there's
no way I just happen to remember it because it was a
particularly striking piece also the vice-president asked me
about it I rarely speak with her so I sit out
It was all fiction, but with that fantasy world absolutely
consuming imagination, urban legends are legends precisely
because they cannot be fully explained or understood.
You have a point.
If lore can be borne from emotions other than fear, then...
Is there anything else you're looking for?
If you'd excuse me, I need to organize some books now.
I realize this may sound overly personal, but have you
enjoyed any media recently?
I'd appreciate a recommendation.
skip a skip a how could i choose um have you heard of
magical girl heavy caliper oh my gosh and rc and i did that
event too yeah people of the port too so this is also a
field mission field exploration so we'll be going around
sometimes you get missions where you you know go around like
this but other times usually you'll get missions where you
where you attack.
Where you have to like...
It's kind of nice because you get to use like different
students that maybe you don't have in your party that you
haven't recruited yet.
And so, uh...
Um...
Yeah.
Uh, you can try them in like the battles in this.
Mm-hmm.
Fox 2 reporting in.
I've just entered point alpha.
Roger that, requesting reports from the remaining squad
members.
Fox 3 and Fox 4 are stationed at Point Sierra.
I'm on the lookout and will remotely support Fox 2, just
like last time.
Copy that.
Today's mission objective is to discern the whereabouts of
subject Miaguchi, the missing fisherman.
We were unable to learn anything about him during our last
outing.
Most people affiliated with the port seem indifferent to the
crab barrel rumors last time.
Keep an eye out today.
We could be overlooking something.
Roger!
Yeah, the new Explore Mission types are cool in general
story.
Yeah, they were like an event sometimes, but now you got
them here too.
By the way, Fox One, did you learn anything new during your
personal investigation yesterday?
My investigation.
Yeah, you stepped out in the afternoon because you wanted to
look into something.
Uh...
Right, yesterday.
It was nothing.
Strictly a personal matter.
A personal matter.
Is there a problem for you?
Box 3?
Not at all.
I just never heard of you caring about personal matters
before.
And on a day off?
Is there a reason for this change of heart?
Maybe Yukino changed some because Minto Sensei is watching!
I'm watching!
I'm watching.
That's enough idle chatter.
Focus on the mission.
It's on you, Fox 2.
Woohoo, get started!
Alright, guys.
We might have to...
Hmm.
We might have to go through this pretty fast.
I mean, I don't mind if I go over.
But, let's talk to this guy.
Oh, hello.
Hello.
Let me talk to you.
We're zooming a little bit.
Sorry, I got so into the other stuff before.
Hello?
Huh?
Aren't you the student who brought us United Zushi?
I don't suppose you're here for another promotion.
Let's see, we're gonna skip a little bit.
Lots of leftover energy drinks.
I'm too proud to take a free drink.
Romantic Sailor!
Did you catch a lot of crab today?
Sure did.
We thought our ship was going to sink.
I'd feel a lot cheerier about it if the crabs were actually
worth something.
so much kind of think of it did you crap catch these crabs
with baited traps traps caught and fishing nets are spring
traps often have broken legs or claws but seem to be in
great but these seem to be in great shape are we speaking
his language you're not like most kids huh if they're in
today's earth are your kind of initiative we wouldn't have
such a hard time finding good help are you having problems
hiring people it's nothing big we were having trouble
finding our new fish or our new guy Miyaguchi just
disappeared I can't believe me how good you ran off without
a word if I ever run into that punk again I'm gonna give him
a good kick in the rear the kids these days right how
problematic maybe well what if he had a good reason maybe
something happened to him if he had a serious illness or
sudden accident oh sorry there's no way that kid certainly
got sick sorry if I keep yawning my cat Johnny
I'm sure he went, ran away because crabbing was too hard.
He whined every day about it.
He only asked, we only asked him to maintain the equipment.
Does crabbing work that hard?
I can't say it's easy, but everyone with strong constitution
and have a brain cell can do it.
Oh, have a brain, not a brain cell.
You yawned yourself, it might have been me.
Also, don't say yawned.
You make me yawned.
I'm not lying about him, by the way.
Ask the others.
The whole crew knew about what a whiny little noodle he was.
Kids nowadays.
Alright.
I guess it's confirmed fact that Sailor named Miyaguchi
disappeared.
Let's try to ask the other fishermen if they know anything.
Oh.
Oh, wow.
I love the sleuthing music.
It's so good.
Excuse me.
Looks like you're...
working hard today too.
Why not take a break and enjoy a complimentary ice cold
energy drink?
Let's see.
Some guy missing.
Mia something.
Old man's rambling on again.
Don't worry about the kid.
Happens all the time to...
All the time?
Is fishing work that rough?
Plenty of kids quit.
It's hard work out here.
Lonely too.
Well, Miyaguchi wasn't as lazy as the old man says.
Yeah, he complained a lot, but he got the job done.
Did his work well?
He might have had an accident, but I reckon he ran off
because of his debt.
Ugh.
Debt.
Lots of fishers hop on the boat to pay off their debt or
escape it.
Sure, the work is rough and sometimes dangerous, but you can
make a lot in a short period, provided the wind's blowing
right.
I heard Miyaguchi was a gambler.
A fool.
He is a red panda.
He's so cute.
No, sorry.
He's a fisherman.
Looks like he got a loan from the...
Oh!
I'm so sorry, the Carpaccio family.
Carpaccio, that sounds yummy.
Making me think of pasta.
The ones in black minding the gate.
No one gets in or out without talking to them.
Dun, dun, dun.
This is their territory, and they happen to run security at
Kanesaki Port.
They offer loans to people with bad credit.
As you'd expect, the Carpaccio family charges an absurdly
high interest.
There's no way Miyaguchi could pay it off.
I'm sure he ran away before his debt grew too big for him.
I see, that's so scary.
Stay away from gambling tables, everybody!
Don't go to Vegas!
And private loons!
Why the fisherman disappeared?
Hmm, yeah.
If he was trying to escape his debt, he wouldn't have taken
the main gate and gone towards.
Maybe I should look for clothes around the harbor.
Hmm.
you do not
never ever work on a crabbing boat no matter how much cash
strapped you are I barely managed to get away oh wait an
open frenzy max really that's totally a bait post
only I hadn't sipped from that frenzy max with an open lid
I love mountain Someone I knew said they were going on a
crabbing boat Never heard back from that person Okay
Post-mortem Oh, we can't go that way Just kidding Kitty, I
want to pet you But I don't have time
Smells fishy Who is gonna drink from that?
Maybe I'll talk to them by the gates.
Nope.
Any...
Oh.
What do we see?
Is this a railway track?
The railway track must be how they transport seafood to
other regions.
Can they transport people through it?
People, people.
Oh, crab fried rice.
That sounds so good.
Good!
Guys, I'm hungry for dinner.
Oh, here we go.
Hungry for dinner.
It's peaceful!
So there was a station here.
You wouldn't be able to leave the port by train without
passing through here.
Maybe a station attendant saw the missing treasurer.
Yes!
Hello!
Hi-hi!
I don't think I've seen you here before.
Are you new in town?
What are you having tonight?
I don't know yet.
Not people.
From Bento Delivery to Restaurant Recommendations, we are
Delivery Agency Fox Eats.
Alright, I'm sorry.
We're gonna have to skip through a little bit of this more.
I do want to go through the...
What was it?
The Weeds Don't Bloom Alone mini story.
Just a little bit, just a little bit.
At least like one episode.
So I think what we'll do is we'll unfortunately skip this.
We'll go to the ending of this and see kind of like what
the, you know, the end of day summary is.
Should I try using a shortcut?
Look how cute she looks, with her little scheming face.
Fox 3, do you copy?
This is Fox 3, currently on Standboy at Point Sierra.
What do you need?
Can you breach the Highlander Academy's transportation
management system?
I need the boarding records.
I probably can't hack the Highlander Academy's database
directly, but their data is shared with the General Student
Council's Transportation Office.
I'll check there.
What are you looking for?
Miyaguchi.
know if he boarded a commuter train starting at Kanesaki
port the day he went missing.
And make sure to check the days before he and after he went
missing, just in case.
I need some time to crack the server.
I should have a definitive answer by the time we get back to
HQ.
Yeah, I'll leave you to it.
Wheat story is great, you love it?
Oh, I'm excited.
Ride, history!
Look how cute he is!
Confirm the escape route via train.
Come to think of it that fisherman supposedly borrowed money
from the Carpaccio family.
Maybe the Carpaccio family knows the whereabouts of the
fisherman.
Suspicious.
I'm sure you got the right train ticket.
I heard lots of people get off at the wrong station because
DU's hub has confusing transfer routes.
No way.
Maybe it's possible in an academy district, but there's no
way you can get a train with the wrong ticket in DU proper.
The moment they find out you have the wrong ticket, those
Highlander girls will grab you by the coat and throw you
off.
So aggressive.
Alright.
So unfortunately, we will have to skip all this.
Wee!
I'll just have to go back and do it later.
But look how cute they are!
Look how cute!
So let's see.
Fox Squad concludes that the missing fishermen failed to pay
back the Carpaccio family.
However, you can no notice is something odd and decides to
start another investigation.
But you guys can solve it.
You guys can figure it out.
it all out by downloading blue archive and playing yourself
sleepy otogi too cute like i said just by reading i mean
there are so many stories there's so many chapters and so
many episodes within the chapters that you just get so much
so many pyros just by reading the story and enjoying blue
archive
Fine, maybe I will.
Yeah, maybe I should.
Maybe I should.
There is a lot of text.
Weeds don't grow alone.
So we'll probably just do this first episode of it.
We've arrived.
We're finally here.
All of us are here at a fine dining restaurant in a
five-star hotel.
The music is so good.
I'm Ian, I literally cannot read.
You can, I believe in you.
But being at a place like this with Haru, I can die with no
regrets.
Well, well, are you sure about this, Haru?
This place looks like it caused some serious coin.
It's pocket change.
Thanks to how hard you all have been working, we're actually
in the greed.
Ah!
Music always means shenanigans, but fancy.
I know.
That's a great way to put it.
You shouldn't overdo it, though.
This much is fine.
Completely fine.
Too many texts to read.
No, I believe in you.
Reading is good for you.
And look, you also get to look at cute girls.
We even have some actual savings now.
Because if I can't do it, at the least, this much for my
employees how can i call myself the boss so stop thinking
about money and just enjoy yourselves thank you nicholas
can't say i don't follow orders just in case you did call
ahead and make a reservation right kaioko's dress is insane
though i feel like my girl's about to go clubbing i don't
know about a fancy restaurant They are all so cute though.
That's a given.
Excuse me, waiter.
Yes, welcome.
We have a reservation under Riku Hachima.
Oh yes, I see you on the list.
This way, please.
How are you?
Uts, Uts, Uts, Uts.
So fancy.
Wow.
It will be this table right by the window.
Wow, by the window.
Hmm.
She looks so like, yes.
Allow me to walk you through the pre-fixed courses you've
reserved.
The main dish is the chef's special, wild hunt-styled beef
tenderloin stew.
This signature piece stands out for the sauce we simmer in.
with a deglazed meat juice and low acidity wine to capture
the full richness of the flavor we additionally serve the
waiter's lengthy explanation of the menu continued on
everybody's faces everybody's just like and fusion all then
tear bruh and brun brun noise what brun brun was it was an
endless barrage of terms that they'd never heard before.
They don't know al dente?
Ahem!
Sounds perfect.
We look forward to it.
Yes.
Then we'll prepare the Amuse Boucher.
Got Mutsky on the first poll?
So happy for you.
I'm so happy for you.
Hi, Johnny.
My cat's here.
I think he's also hungry for dinner.
Aru, be honest.
Do you even know what they said?
Oh, something along the lines of them being top tier dishes.
This place is expensive, so I'm sure the dishes are going to
be delicious.
Don't sweat the small stuff.
Come here, Johnny.
even the waiter in oh the what not the waiter the water here
is different I guess apparently it's mineral water melted
from pure glacier ice what kind of clientele comes to a
place like this you're making dinner invite me over oh this
is their clientele dogs and cats and shebes Wow a rich one
that's for sure Tonight, we're part of that clientele, so
there's no need for comparisons.
And we're dressed better, too.
Are you sure we're not actually overdressed?
We're not!
We're dressed actually as we should be, right?
It's perfect for an elegant meal, okay?
I see.
You must be familiar with etiquette and fancy pants places
like this.
Then do you know how to use the fork and knives?
I was curious as well.
Why are they all different sizes?
Oh, well!
I guess you're supposed to use different cutlery depending
on what part of the meal you're on.
Oh my gosh, Kayoko's so smart.
I don't know.
What's... what's for what, though?
Who cares which one you use?
It's not like the choice of fork makes the food taste
different.
Mm-hmm.
Oh, hey, who's causing all this ruckus?
I'm the hotel VIP.
Oh, look at over there, interlopers.
Hmm, are you talking about us?
Did you just insult Aru?
Aru-sama?
Aru.
Wait, come to think about your problem solver 68.
Excuse me, but who are you?
You!
You dare not recognize me!
Feelings like you are nothing special.
You expect us to remember a big old nobody?
It's me, Bruno Rigatoni, from the Rigatoni family!
Surely you remember that name at least?
Rigatoni family?
Don't tell me.
Come to think of it, you're...
You do remember!
And you probably know what I'm going to do next!
Mamma Mia!
My time for revenge has come!
Everybody!
I'm from the Fettuccini family.
Oh my gosh!
Triplets!
Seriously?
Here, right now...
Pro's name is a pasta.
Do you know how much money I've spent here?
I practically own the place.
I could do whatever I want.
Oh, I've been willing to let you run free up until now, but
I'm not a man who lets good opportunities slip through my
fingers.
It sure will be satisfying to repay this grudge.
Everyone, wipe them out!
And the rest of it!
This too is Blue Archive, everybody.
This too is Blue Archive.
Okay.
with this I didn't expect this kind of welcome what's the
move boss if we break anything in here the repair bill won't
be cheap that's probably true but we don't have any other
choice running away isn't hard-boiled at all everyone return
fire so cool Aru that's the spirit yes leave it to me Aru I
will wipe the I'm all out!
Yeah!
And the whole restaurant cheered.
Dinner and a show, baby.
The sudden shootout broke out in the hotel's restaurant.
What happened between Problem 68 and the Rigatoni family?
Find out.
To be continued on the next episode of Weeds Don't Grow
Alone!
Zee!
you guys have to see what happens me too
I'll also have to see
well guys we didn't actually get to the Momo talks which
makes me so sad but
well oh geez oopsie I have so many my bad my bad
There she is.
Another fun-filled day.
Sensei.
What do you think of my laugh?
Cute.
Do you guys think her laugh is cute?
Funny.
It's cute.
Is that what you think?
What if I laugh differently?
like oh or what's this for nothing serious I'm just testing
out a new angle do you want to discuss it in person and then
you can talk the imp and the villainous well guys I hope you
enjoyed playing a blarker with me I hope you Evil cute laugh
That was a pretty good Thank you I hope you guys enjoyed my
voice acting Sorry that I guess the voice acting kind of It
adds a little bit of a A little bit of extra Extra time
because I have to You know read so much Thank you for the
stream Thank you Nexon for sponsoring Me too I love Problem
Solver 68 so much Thank you Thank you again Nexon I get a
little shy When... when... I don't know.
I don't know why.
I just...
Like I said, I usually play by myself, so when I show off
my...
Wait...
No!
I was ranked 25 earlier.
Wake me!
Thank you!
Hoo!
Darko, thank you so much for the pink!
Nah.
At least you purple.
I'm purple!
Yeah.
Like I said, I just get a little shy.
Because it is my... This is my personal account, you guys.
So it's kind of crazy.
But...
My lust for revenge grows.
I'm orful.
But yeah.
Thank you guys.
I had a lot of fun.
I don't...
to show this off.
I guess I could stream it, but it's kind of like one of my
just my like hobbies, not hobbies, like you know, like an
off work type of thing that I like to do.
So, off stream.
I play games sometimes, you know.
I don't play very, honestly I don't play gotcha games at
all.
Blue Archive is my only one that I play, so it is very dear
to me.
And I'm really honored that Nexon has brought me on so many
times at this point.
I'm really, really thankful, really grateful, and really
honored.
So, so thank you so much.
Thank you so much.
Yeah, so I hope if you guys saw this little glimpse of...
other like uh there's other like side missions and
everything that you can do there's always something to do on
the game so i uh i recommend it it's you know you can play
as much or as little as you want there's a great story if
this was your first time kind of getting into more seeing
more blue archive stuff i hope you enjoyed it and if you are
also a uh deep in it say like i am then hopefully you had
fun uh exploring the the new chapter with me and everything
and the episodes with me it's my do a little bit every day
game yeah
so i recommend it even if i wasn't sponsored i've talked to
i but you know before before i was ever sponsored by them i
would talk about how blue archive was my game so is this
minky eat can i Sorry, it's not midnight right now, so
you'll have to wait.
But yeah, I had so much fun.
I hope you guys did as well.
And yeah!
Have fun!
Sensei is carry on, carry on, carry on.
Otsumeito!
Eterasha everybody!
Thank you so, so, so, so, so much for joining me today.
Thank you again, Nexon.
And yeah!
Thanks for the stream, Minto!
Thank you for hanging out with me!
Thank you!
Sorry that I had to rush a few things.